you know enter welcome to this video
play to walk to Boggs recently beat me
quite badly when I was having black in a
banker where trick me with the move on
and I really hope to get some revenge in
[Music]
its really awfully optional chest she
learn but it is it is fishy but it is
not so bad that white can win outright I
[Music]
don't know maybe I have to take it but i
have never checked this line in any
reasonable detail
okay so that he can so long it's not so
easy here for white to get at the king I
mean the King looks a little bit shaky
there but he often oh it was that was
quick huh never thought that is that
clear cut what do I want to keep this
piece don't think so
[Music]
ok coming with f4 huh hey he's also
quite quick here with his stuff yeah
[Music]
very dangerous
why Rick my deceit play that's so
quickly is it all that easy probably yes
I'm the only one having difficulty with
those positions c3 what's what's the
deal am I getting chick made it here I
have to what's going on what a difficult
game if he gets to a 4 i'm probably
getting chick made it so he's taking g
form
you
[Music]
Wow getting out of the 63 sort of check
anymore yeah still on our to g5 so I'm
going to go here and threaten g5 yeah so
what's going on if i take night takes
probably so let's go 35
I wonder which is six or something yeah
I probably have to take so if we trade
our trade now my king is so problematic
there on the back rank but rook chicks I
can actually take whether it's Godric g6
though okay let's do this I cannot spend
more time here it might be might be bad
the ending might be bad my bad king and
the econ that could be problematic so
I'm going back defy this week that was
an idea of course
something please it's better there than
on d1 hmm so I can go here and I can can
probably get the a pawn and the beep on
and it beep on is more important time
let's go for the veep on yes the you
pawned oh crap crap ending but I need to
get to be porn I mean
e to King situated should be ok so we
wants to play time morning store should
be good mmm check check check now maybe
I could have gone look g5 actually no I
wouldn't be for here right now he's
losing the thread
check check check 23 in seconds check
check still 20 seconds Oh No okay have
crew check also draw off your check I
won't take it check check check game
drawn hmm not winning this is terrible
really come on how could I not win this
and somehow get him giving activity or
whatever here that's terrible Minch I
can just what does he get anything here
actually maybe it can just push the beep
some things is just this is the kind of
play I really hate to lose or draw draw
is like a loss here most you this kind
of mindless instant play in totally
complex positions and he got into a lost
position because it simply didn't try to
do anything yeah and when you get there
and you spoil them everything yeah as
this ending is tricky it's not easy and
I was really having some doubts there
because of my bad King position but it
seems it seems to be okay no when he was
really feeling very you cooperate to
check and going into this into this bad
ending even hear you can you can at
least try now come on I need a break